[Music]
the movies that we get exclusively we
offer to churches exclusively so it's
like you're bringing people to the
church instead of the theater we suggest
churches do an outdoor event it's none
threatening for the guy that doesn't
want to go to church but he gets to go
there and be in the midst of those that
are gathered in a guy Jesus was doing he
was going out into the communities and
reaching yeah he wasn't necessarily
calling them into the synagogue to have
a conversation
[Music]
hey we're doing a show today with two
Christian creators I got David and Tammy
and we're going to talk about you know
Christian media media in general how can
we use this tool this very powerful
creative tool that we often are against
but how can we use it for the glory of
God how can we use it to reach the world
and even more like how do we reach the
secular world how are we going to get
the secular world and bring them into
the church and is that even possible
using media so our first question we
have is what's your background and what
got you into production I'm gonna ask
David first yeah so my background I'm an
entrepreneur and inventor I consider
myself a disrupter from the
entrepreneurial standpoint
I got into e-commerce after coming out
of construction right around the age 30
and that was right around the timeline I
became a Christian I actually
um I'm going to touch on what got me
interested in production before
finishing my background so
um I received the Lord after going to a
movie event at a church the movie was
The Da Vinci Code which was not oh
that's interesting yeah it wasn't a
movie that was there to preach you down
by no means but we get to this church
and people are outside protesting like
throwing all kinds of hate at this
pastor because he's shown this movie
because he's showing the movie yeah so
so at the end of the movie I just raised
my hand and I asked a question and that
that led into
um participating in some follow-up Bible
studies wow and a few months later I
received the Lord along with maybe about
a dozen other people that were there at
that event wow uh so right around that
time I left construction real estate and
I got into e-commerce this was in
um
this is really at a time when social
media was emerging and the search engine
Optima optimization was emerging mobile
technology was emerging it was before we
had access to video phones and all the
good stuff we have today so it was
really a great time to enter into
e-commerce and learn things as they were
developing we became
um
my team and I became part of you know
what developed e-commerce is what it is
today so learning landing pages and
learning the four elements of conversion
and really mastering that Craft
[Music]
um I got out of that business went into
um I was invited to take a look at a
laboratory that was a DARPA funded and
SBR funded lab oh wow did they
specialized in weapon Material Sciences
and making like uh robotic dogs and
things like that too no they made they
made materials for weapons okay yeah so
they're looking for someone to come in
and commercialize a portfolio so I built
a team to come in and do that created a
partnership company with them and got
into the weapon Sciences space and end
up Consulting with quite a bit of
companies that are involved in
military activity basically so your
background nothing to do with movies but
listen to the movies yet but this church
that showed this secular movie Intrigue
something about the Bible to you yeah so
I realized uh within the first few
months of my walk how
backward thinking that I was as someone
that didn't understand the Bible yeah
and I thought man if there's billions of
people out there thinking the way I used
to think wow this world's not very good
right so um so you saw the darkness that
kind of yeah when you experience going
from someone that I mean I grew up in
Blue Collar so I heard the most foul
language on job sites and you know
everybody talk like Sailors um
and then all of a sudden you're around
God-fearing people and it's just a night
and day difference it was a really
really good God love experience and then
um going down the road a few months
later having my first Holy Spirit
interaction and that's when I realized
like okay like I really want to get this
out there how do I get like how do I
Mass produce this result
um so do you think you probably had no
interest in going into a church but it
was because of this movie of what what
Broadway said that uh a friend of mine
called me and said hey you like watching
movies I said sure she's like no I was
actually my cousin yeah she's like you
want to come to this church I'm like no
she's like oh they're playing a Tom
Hanks movie announced Tom Hanks fan yeah
okay and I said I'll go to church and
watch Tom Hanks I'm gonna be so I did oh
okay and I was really shocked to see the
protesters outside
um you know and you know someone slapped
my car when we were driving in there and
I just thought well this whole thing's
kind of weird you know yeah what
question did you asked uh so I asked the
question I said well if Jesus and Mary
had a kid can't we just get their DNA in
injected in everybody to make us all
like super power people you know I
didn't know and the guy was like fast
you need to go to study great question
by the house so I did and um it was a
men's group that night in in
um I felt like a complete after
asking the question because I realized
um it wasn't true like I went to the I
went thinking I'm going to receive uh of
some secret code that DaVinci had in
some painting the that's what I was
expecting that had some kind of like
biblical magical connection yeah
um and I end up connecting to the Holy
Spirit which is way more than any code
than any man could have ever written
amen
so this movie was used in a way that
changed my life and put me on a brand
new course well
um so yeah I know I was I'm someone that
dives deep into anything I do I don't
waste any time so I don't I dove really
deep into it next you know I'm I'm uh I
started off like my first Bible teacher
was Dr Harold Camping oh wow yeah do you
remember him yeah this date Setter guy
that's all I know about yeah he's a date
Setter
um but uh
you know I went from that to listening
to CSN Radio all day long and and
anywhere I could just getting the gospel
warmer and good all day yeah hungry and
I would have it playing on job sites
okay which wasn't very popular yeah
right uh so anyway so there's all this
conflict going on so I started asking
the Lord just to um take me out of that
and give me something else wow and he
did and I started the e-commerce company
and learned started learning the
internet but then we you start learning
like the really dark side of online
entrepreneurship or it's it's all based
on deception and back then everybody's
running these these free offers to get
free stuff and none of it was free oh
yeah eventually you're getting charged
right yeah yeah so I started seeing just
the the you know getting into online
entrepreneurship and now as a Christian
seeing the people that are putting
everything in front of us all day long
and driving us to these offers and
selling us these products they're broken
like really broken
um everyone that I've met that wanted to
do business with us they wanted to meet
in a strip club or they wanted they had
some dream of having let's let's make a
marketing video and have some Playmate
in the video and there's all there's all
around like worldliness you know so
so I got into there then I'm like okay
Lord I don't want to be involved in this
anymore I don't like this craft uh so I
got into a couple of other things that
some things we talked about last night
we'll have to get into that
um
and got into the weapon Material Science
space and and through that saw the
Brokenness
um some of the guys that we dealt with
were doing sex traffic interception wow
so we Dove pretty deep into that world
saw a lot of the Brokenness in that
world which is yeah
uh what I thought was probably the most
terrific things that we saw in that
space which wasn't yeah it was I mean my
life would take me down God would take
me down a journey
to show me things a lot darker than that
even
um so I ended up building a team we
invented a process to suck ink out of
the skin to get rid of eyelid tattoos
for you know sex traffic victims
um
and that got into some political things
and that's where the real darkness
that's where the real deception and
that's where when you look at when you
look at politics and you look at media
and the way that they when those two
worlds come together it's a hundred
percent about deception so uh in the mid
2000 teens uh getting into a lot of that
space I started the scripture kept
coming up where Jesus tells us not to be
deceived and here I you know I would
watch
I would watch marketing efforts by
political people driving people in
drones to vote for the most corrupt
individuals out there who have who have
no interest in protecting children
whatsoever and people are like people
from the church just dropping ballots
that Jordan slamming the ball right so
anyway uh and I realized like something
there has to be a change in media there
has to be a shift in culture and media
creation
um
but all in my opinion it came down to
the purpose in which media is created
so there's got to be there's got to be
something out there that creates media
with a different intention right um and
it's not about building a brand it's not
about building self
um
so I decided to go down that road so I
went to a lot of Christian film
production companies
um I I wrote something called the
excitement curve thesis where
I wrote I wrote a theory on
um what happens when you when you go
past the excitement curve and your brand
isn't really exciting anymore right oh
yeah uh there's a a Christian like when
pureflix said God's Not Dead that was
like the tip of their excitement curve
the the that that money making brand
right how do you like repeat that over
and over again so
so I went to the pretty much the whole
world of Christian Media and I'm like
hey I think I think we need to go this
new Direction and um
God would allow the doors to be closed
on our love
and ultimately
um
I had an offer to exit the tattoo
removal
space and at that same time I had an
offer to come to Hollywood
and uh
was there first Dales in Beverly Hills
you know have the meetings and I did a
call asking me to go to a meeting with
an actor
by this time the word was out that I was
interested in making non-faith movies
uh to allow churches to drive
non-christians to movie events yeah and
the Word was out that I was doing it
so a lot of people in the Christian
Media space put the word out there like
don't take David's calls
um like this guy does not need any
traction right because it's a threat to
her it's a threat to our bottom line if
this guy takes off so so ultimately
um
uh the guy that ended up sitting at the
table with was Rob Schneider wow and
yeah he recently became a Christian
right like three years ago
um yeah he said he you know his uh his
mother was Catholic
um so he has Catholic ties as a kid and
that's when he met the Lord as a young
person but
he got into the got into Hollywood and
uh you know um I think he referred to it
as the white the white
white hot light of flame or something
the white hot flame him
a fame or something you know got him and
um you know and he's he's brought back
um
and and you know Rob said you know Jesus
is like that jealous lover and called
you back wow you know and he called Rob
back so amen see how the Lord put in
Rob's heart to show up with us to come
to meet me at the at the meeting and we
talked for several hours and and then
just started communicating back and
forth and relaying you know this is the
this the dream and
he had some movie ideas and uh right
right after covid when when the coveted
restrictions were kind of on the decline
he called me and said hey uh
they got an idea what you know let's
talk about it so I went down and spent
some time with him
um
and he didn't really even tell me there
was a plan to make a movie yet he just
like here's an idea well
um
uh last year July
I'm living out of a truck broke homeless
nothing and he calls me and goes hey the
movie's done and I'm like dude uh you're
talking to like a broke Joe homeless and
bum right now all right
um and he's like well let's get it done
click it hangs up on me so check out the
movies so I did and um
I watched the movie and I just I just
did this uh six month speaking tour in
the political world
and had seven bucks to my name my truck
ran out of gas I'm in the middle of
nowhere in Kansas and uh
I get a I'll get a call from someone
that owed me some money and that led
into
me about three hours after seeing
watching the movie I get fifty thousand
dollars right while I'm in a truck right
so I'm like okay Lord I'll um
you know I'll do this and three weeks
later
um sitting in the headquarters of the
world's largest retailer with Rob
um
and a few weeks later sitting at the
table with one of the biggest producers
in the world saying hey let's let's
let's do this partnership
so the Lord brought some of the most
talented people in Hollywood
um to come to the table to say let's
make let's make great stuff
and let's use it for your cause
so in that cause of mine is to
you know I don't have a mission to make
everybody Christian I don't have no
authority over anyone's heart but we
have a mission just to help help church
and the community come together with
something
and that something is just a fun movie
title it's not there's no there's no
agenda in our movie
um
and that's the point No Agenda whereas
Hollywood has a huge agenda to shove
this lifestyle down your throat and all
that yeah so you know the red blue
political divides that have been
wreaking havoc in our society for the
last especially the last 15 years or so
maybe 20 years
um our movies give
church is an opportunity to just reach
out to the community and say let's just
be friends you know
um
yeah if they want to if they want to um
go to the event and learn about the Lord
and
then feel free to ask someone from the
church hey tell me about Jesus if they
know then you just go home and have a
good memory of sitting down watching a
good movie you know
um
so that's that's what we're doing so I
mean and they have missed it but for
someone who is hearing this and it's
like wow this is a really cool idea what
role exactly did you play because so so
someone had an idea and they made a film
and then you were contacted so what what
how was that partnership what role did
you play in yeah what were all my
playing personally yeah so
um
so I built movie night and which is a uh
a platform for churches to to stream the
movie from
um and it became
the the vision of movie night was to
create a a new way for Content creators
to monetize films okay
so we reimagined
Commerce and how Commerce and media can
come together
and how on the monetization side on the
commercial aspect of it we offer Movie
Makers a way to make money that they
would never have made money before
without this process so it was that a
pre-coveted thought
yeah yeah so okay back in my time of
doing internet Commerce I created a
process to basically find out what
people were looking for but not getting
their hands on
and this took legislation into account
this took Trends into it factored all
these different aspects and Broadwell
together and I could say wow
20 million people are going to be
looking for red shoelaces tomorrow why
is that well some famous person a little
red shoes or something right so but
sometimes it spit out data that said hey
here's a emerging market or here's
something that's not serviced properly
or here's something that's not serviced
at all
and we stumbled across the fact that
loyalty loyalty programs
were not loyalty programs do not service
the customer properly and they don't
service the merchant or the business
owner property okay
so we thought well how do we create uh a
universal loyalty program that everyone
would want to be part of okay and we
created it it's movienight.com it's a
it's a third party loyalty process that
allows Merchants to offer
uh offer our new crypto tokens that can
only be used in our environment to rent
buy or subscribe to streaming content
the the subsidiary of movie night is
movie night Ministries where we offer
these are the movies that we get
exclusively we offer to churches
exclusively
so the churches get an exclusivity
window on all of our movies to do these
community events with
so
by shifting uh so it's like you're
bringing people to the church instead of
the theater
well the church are the church are so we
we suggest churches do an outdoor event
you know it's it's threatening for most
non-believers to go into the church so
run apart yeah so yeah so reduce that
threat Factor we just say hey why don't
you just
partner with an HOA or partner with the
fire department or partner somewhere and
just serve everybody that shows up in
the environment that you get to create
and kind of control okay so it's none
threatening for the guy that doesn't
want to go to church but he gets it
he gets to go there and be in the midst
of those that are gathered and then die
and that's kind of following the church
is a sponsor yeah yeah what Jesus was
doing he was going out into the
communities and reaching yeah he wasn't
necessarily calling them into the
synagogue to have a conversation and
your story is another case of God taking
a passion or like a skill of of yours
pre-christian and using that same uh
skill to impact those as you are a
Christian and use it for him I will say
though there are advantages if you can
get them to come to your church oh yeah
sure
um because then they're familiar with
things that you don't normally think
about through the process like but if
they've been there now they know where
the bathrooms are at they know where
they're meeting for worship you know
they they feel comfortable because
they've been there before you have all
these factors that play in if you do get
them in the doors of the church yeah
there's there's a pretty high likelihood
of people attending a church after
coming to movie event
um it's a good question yeah are you
familiar with a company called Grace
Hill Media no so Greece Hill Media is a
marketing company that is like an arm of
Hollywood to
Market films to faith-based audience
Okay so they look at something like
um Superman Returns which if you were
following the media during that time had
huge Christian overtones in it all the
headlines we're talking Fox News
Entertainment Weekly you name it we're
going like you know Jesus flying to a
church near you and this kind of thing
they developed sermons yeah for pastors
they gave them trailer and media clips
for the movies and it's like they handed
the movie to them on a silver platter
which I thought was is brilliant
marketing perspective because yeah it's
essentially free advertising for
Hollywood yeah because you know you you
well I mean however many people are in
the church some churches are larger than
others but anywhere from 100 to you know
what 10 000 people yeah that you're just
marketing this film to yeah and trying
to bring out the faith
overtones or undertones see if you will
yep but
essentially motivated by by Hollywood
and whatever their agenda is not
necessarily I mean there's there's like
strings attached really yeah it's almost
like Hollywood trying to get in
infiltrate the church instead of being
that way around like we're trying to
infiltrate the world and have them come
into the church they have to spin the
story to sell even my opinion on that
good police yeah so
uh there are a group of marketing people
out there that I think should be uh
um deeply ashamed of themselves because
they are they are using their skill sets
to infiltrate the local body
and
I think that's I think it's wrong for
them to do that I know I know who that
company is by the way um as you're
talking that came to my mind but um
they get paid you know we have a lot of
access to churches now so we have offers
coming to us every single day from some
movie company saying hey can you get
churches to get behind this because
the pastor is the micro influencer okay
so you get that guy behind your brand
you get his you get his crowds behind it
yeah
um and the the church
if you go to Pat if you go to a pastor
right now and you say hey Pastor I've
got a movie you want to check it out
um they'll close their ears and walk
away they feel very abused by Hollywood
um
starting you know the first big church
promoted movie was passionate Christ
right
um
and the people that were involved in
that figured out like well we can
there's a there's a huge monetary
benefit if I can get past if I can get a
pass or something I can get paid for
giving him something if I can scale that
I can get paid a lot of money
so these Brands were built around doing
that and a lot of people a lot of people
started doing that
um
but the problem is the pastor the
Pastors in the local congregations were
used they had they gained nothing in
Hollywood gained a lot of value off of
that
so now
if you talk to a lot of pastors they say
no the people all these marketing people
in Hollywood they've treated the body of
Christ like it's horror for for them to
use and monetize and then we got nothing
other than hey here's some free
materials to use so we can infiltrate
your congregation all right so
I'm I'm like extremely far against that
we we came up with a process that offers
the pastor and his kind of mission
something to gain by leveraging a movie
yeah uh yeah I'm guessing you have a
guessing you're you don't just take any
film
no there's a screening process somebody
comes to you and they're like hey we got
this film Bureau platform yeah do you
have a board do you have like a bunch of
screeners like yeah I mean you have
written up policies I'm guessing like
this is what we'll take this is what
we're not going to take and then you run
it by an audience and they're like
thumbs up thumbs down what's that look
like yeah so we um uh our team looks at
a movie we have one one number one rule
it can't offend the word of God
so if anything in their friends the word
of God if we can pull something out and
get rid of it then
and it's not offending to the word of
God then we would be happy with that
um it doesn't have to have any kind of a
gospel message it has to be family
friendly it has to attract attract an
audience to come and sit with us to
watch the movie
um but it cannot offend the word of God
so we get a movie then you know we have
dozens and dozens of pastors we'll send
it to you saying hey watch this what do
you guys think we'll just survey we let
the customer tell us if they want her or
not
um
but for the most part we haven't had
anything come to us because everyone
knows we're we have a church-facing side
of our brand and most people know you
can't put that in front of a church
Hollywood knows you can't get that in
front of a church you know
um you know back up until the late 60s
early 70s
um Hollywood knew that if there was a
scene where a woman was in a bedroom she
had to have one foot on the floor and
you know not not both feet off the floor
sitting on the sexually suggestive so
they know all the rules they know what
they can and can't do and they're
experts at it and they have teams of
lawyers that go through their scripts
and look at their movies and you know
advise them on hey you know we should or
should not do this
um
so uh most people that come to us the
the we do get a lot of movies that um
you know
Christian movies
um you know in all power to the people
out there making Christian movies but
for the most part uh
we're not really into getting you know
we don't want to be the brand saying hey
we have a bunch of fifty thousand dollar
titles you know enjoy you don't want to
entertain Christians you don't want to
preach for the choir you're trying to
reach you're trying to get make a Wise
Fool yeah you're trying to make a tool
to
uh get the world to mingle with
Christians and say hey I can have fun
with these people and they're actually
nice and they're not like what I thought
they were exactly they get you know show
up to an event you get free popcorn free
Coke yeah get served
I love it man yeah cool idea I want to
ask Tammy so what was your story like
what got you into production you you
wrote a book and you have a cool
backstory I've heard it and I love it so
tell us a little bit about that I
started actually writing books at a very
young age I was a child and trying to
get my mother's attention so I used to
write poems I was bullied in school and
I had a very hard time reading until a
wonderful teacher took me under her wing
and I was so excited about finally
reading and she used Dr Seuss books to
teach me how to read so I write in kind
of that rhyming type writing and uh so I
would slip notes under my my mom's in
her bedroom and try to get her attention
so I started out very young writing and
then I finally got my first book
published in 2020 and it's based thank
you it's entitled the kindergarten and
it's based on the fruit of the spirit
and I was always one that I always like
to please people make people happy and I
think without without God it's hard to
be happy so by implementing the fruits
of the spirit I I wanted to accomplish
that so I got this book published and I
started watching little light Studios
for a couple years and I loved what
y'all were doing so I thought you know
this is really great what they're doing
they're exposing all this dark agenda
you know and I'm trying to teach
children how to
read books that are fulfilling and teach
them the word of God and in a way that's
not so much
pushing religion on children but yet
it's pushing kindness and the fruit of
the spirit but I I thought you know
there's what do kids watch after
watching little light Studios it's like
this is great we're exposing but what
what do kids actually watch and what do
they read so I wanted to start
um
animating my book see I love both these
ideas because I see a need for both of
them you're trying to reach a broader
audience whereas Tammy's trying to rate
the TR the Bible talks about training up
a child how they should go they're being
bombarded with this agenda glamorizing
the occult glamorizing LGBT and all
these things and the question we get all
the time is what can we watch because I
mean Blue's Clues is now bad you know
all these things and it's like well what
is there anything worth watching and so
the the terrible truth the terrible
reality is that there's a bunch of low
budget Christian stuff that doesn't
compete with Hollywood because
Christians who are complaining about
there not being enough Christian content
are still throwing their money at
Hollywood and and
feel some kind of resistance about
Christians asking for money they're like
oh Christians just want our money or
you're trying to make money off the
gospel and all these excuses and it's
like how can we ever produce content if
we don't have the support of the church
you know we're already a minority and
then you're not even going to get the
support so
yeah I love the idea of creating content
that children can watch that is uh it's
teaching them valuable lessons morals
biblical
uh you know Concepts and things like
that and you're not just talking about
books now you're talking about
animations and puppet shows and correct
and touring around to like camps and
things like that this is what kids need
they they need to be filled with content
that is going to make them feel good
about themselves and that glorifies our
father
I love it man I see these working hand
in hand it's almost like a stepping
stone you know people are gonna like you
you weren't even gonna go to church
except for this movie yeah
yeah so we look at we look at media for
two purposes one or attraction and two
edification hmm
um so with movie night we have movies
that'll be edifying that are pretty much
going to be
Christian kind of exclusive events and
then we have stuff that's attraction
okay
um I'm a firm believer in edifying the
body as consistently and frequently as
possible amen so some parents have
decided to limit screen time in their
homes because of the agendas being
pushed and the media today what would
you have them consider when it comes to
Christian Productions
um I think that time on screen should be
very limited
um as far as what what would I depending
on the children's age I would say
um look up gominno.com yeah
I think that's a great service uh
you know kids are are completely cut off
from any exposure of anything that
Christian parents would not want them to
be exposed to I think minnow is doing a
great job with that yeah but I think the
answer is uh parenting time right right
you know and if you parent your kids
right they're not going to watch stuff
that they know is going to offend my dad
yeah
um
so and also remembering that media is a
tool right the tool has been manipulated
by Hollywood for wrong but we've heard
examples how it's been used for right so
in your effort to block screens time
just remember that the screen itself as
a tool and can be used in a positive way
and just because something is being put
on a screen doesn't automatically make
it bad it's for the parent to screen it
you know look at it and then also when
it's deemed appropriate
engage with it with your child as you
say parent time and see what could come
from that because just as you a witness
too
um in a correct setting after a film the
child also can be witnessed to with the
appropriate form of media yeah
absolutely yeah I mean you can watch a
sermon on a screen there's a lot of a
lot of the dangers of screens are the
fast-paced camera changes like all these
things that cause ADHD and all these
things that are you know shorter
attention spans and all that but you can
use it as a learning it's literally like
a white board that you know you can
change what's on the screen you know
yeah and I think as an author it is
really important to engage with children
through books as much as possible but
the reality of it is a lot of these
parents are working and there are going
to be times where children are are going
to be watching videos and you want to
make sure that there's content out there
that's good content for them to watch
yeah otherwise it's just all the garbage
out there that's right so comedy can be
a dicey Avenue to present a message
because the funniest humor is often at
the expense of someone else yeah how do
you balance Christian principles with
making a film funny instead of cheesy uh
I think this is a phenomenal question so
when you look at our movie daddy
daughter trip there's a lot of funny
scenes in there and
all of his all of it is pretty much at
the expense of Rob Schneider's right
Larry Buble but he sprays lotion he
sprays suntan lotion on a on a chair and
rubs it on his back to get lotion on his
back so I guess he but you know that's
him allowing himself to be funny this
question
um
was was addressed a little bit early on
because we were like well we don't want
to see someone like someone do something
to someone else and cause them to get
hurt or make fun of someone so it's at
the expense of someone intentionally
um but
um
you know people being funny I don't like
it getting laughed at I'm not someone
that wants to stand in front of an
audience to get laughed at I don't know
some people love it yeah guys like Rob
Schneider he's like amazing at it he
does his Comedy Tour and people laugh at
him you know a couple nights a week
right now but he does it at the expense
of himself
um in in our movie I guess you could say
Rob's Comedy Tour he probably does have
some funny stuff happening at the
expense of people in the political world
but uh but as far as our movie goes um
uh this is our first comedy and there's
no one really as far as I know uh
getting made fun of or it's at the
expense of someone where there's a funny
scene I don't know you watched the movie
wouldn't right yeah actually the girl
gets the young girl gets teased a lot
but the moral is to not do that you know
you're feeling sorry yeah you know yeah
so that's that's the the kind of thing
too is like it's all about context you
know if you make the movie
glamorizing making fun of somebody
that's wrong but if you show the act of
somebody being made fun of and show the
moral that's what people bring up with
the Bible all the time well there was
adultery in the Bible yeah what was the
outcome it was never good you know there
was polygamy in the Bible it was never
good well like I said in the beginning
it it all goes it all comes down to the
intention in which content's created are
you intending to
um
you know make fun of a certain person in
the media because you know Legends right
or or you know not necessarily this
person in the media but person someone
in general or is your intention just to
Simply give someone laughter and
memories and and when I talked about
this with Rob
he he understood what laughter does like
that you know Hollywood kind of has that
psychology kind of locked down and
understand but laughter creates more
memories than any other emotional
responses and I I didn't really know
that so I didn't know that comedies are
literally the number one way to create
memories during a movie well I don't
know anything we all talk about remember
that thing that guy did that was really
funny yeah yeah you know exactly
um how do you balance Christian
principles with making a film funny
instead of cheesy and instead of cheesy
just have people that know how to be
funny and make movies yeah you know if I
made a movie of Comedy it would not be
funny it would be very cheap that's the
thing too like you have to have a budget
to be able to hire the the actors you
know like yes
pure flicks and and other companies like
that they aren't hiring A-list actors so
the outcome of it's not going to be the
best the acting is not going to be the
best no so so companies like Pure Flix
they took a position in juror Hardline
and one
you know there's just people that
wouldn't cross that hard line to do
anything with them yeah uh and then
because there might be some atheist
celebrity that might be in uh would be
willing to be an actor in one of your
movies because it's not overtly
Christian or whatever it's not pushing
an agenda yeah well I considering yeah
we have we have many
non-believing actors that have reached
out to us saying hey we love to do a
movie with you guys we think we think
uh church is vital for society let us
know how we can participate wow we've
had a lot of those guys in girls so some
are actually interested even if it does
have a highly interested and guys that
are normally getting two to five million
bucks are saying hey I'll work for a
couple hundred grand to be in your movie
like names that are very very well known
yeah that's awesome I can see how that
can get a little difficult because then
you have these different Minds with
these different ideas coming together to
put a product but at the end of the day
although the movie may not be overtly
Christian
um it is trying to create a wholesome
atmosphere to where Christian principles
can be discussed yeah and in using
comedy or whatever Avenue uh as uh the
the means or what is it the end to
justify the means
um it is interesting to see you
referenced the daddy-daughter trip and
how in creating a movie Everything Is
intentional or you have to think of sit
down and think about the script and
think about how you're going to be funny
and all of that so with this question of
balancing the two it's making sure that
that each scene that is used is not only
funny to create an impact but also
doesn't lead someone down into a not so
nice path so yeah the watching the film
yes the humor was very much on Rob this
sorry the humor was very much on Rob and
um it was clear that humor at someone's
expense especially the child Spence was
not okay and they made that clear but
towards the end there was a scene that I
remember where one of the women made a
pass at the actual person Michael Buble
yeah even though she knew that he was
married and so that kind of was
interesting to me because it's like well
that wasn't necessary that it was
towards the end of the film the message
was already out there but that was
slipped in and who knows what that
reason was for because as I said there
was a collective of Mines that were yeah
putting forth the film but just being
careful in that regard
when you're trying to stand on Christian
principle but also making sure that the
movie is still appropriate it's
wholesome it's funny and not cheesy it
can be very difficult to balance that
out because it's like you know yes it's
funny it's a nice ending but also man
that was actually inappropriate in my
opinion like adultery funny right to
make adultery funny yeah and it wasn't a
dress you're right it wasn't addressed
to say oh this is wrong like her friend
didn't say hey you shouldn't you
shouldn't do that or something like that
just left so I'm curious he said I got
edited since like you cut it yeah we cut
several scenes and why why did you cut
it is it because it went to a broader
audience and they give you feedback and
they're like hey would I like that or so
so we have uh we have a follow-up study
that goes with that and we addressed
that in the study okay wow yeah
interesting so we have tools we have a
couple versions of the movie one is
without that scene a couple other scenes
and one is worth it so we'll say hey
Pastor watch golf here's our study
materials uh and you notice their
animations in the movie yes so we have
children devotions around those animated
characters and we talk about Jack squat
yeah and uh the Frog yeah and the cookie
the cookie is you know cookie just
couldn't get set be satisfied he's
always dissatisfied no matter what
anybody did for him so there's all kinds
of stuff yeah yeah so so that that's
that's cool that we're talking about
that that there is this vetting process
and you're getting feedback and you're
considering what people are saying and
yeah that's cool which is good because
it just goes back to this isn't
impossible it just takes effort and
works put out something that's really
good and it makes a big impact yeah I
didn't know that so thank you yeah as
long as you get you know talented people
they come together and make stuff the
movie was almost four million dollars to
make uh and it's the most I think it's
the most uh the highest well it is the
highest budget direct to church release
movie ever wow it's a huge risk it's a
huge experiment
you know it is a risk but I would say if
you know Christian audiences you know
that if you if you
get a product that they like they're
intensely loyal and get behind you 100
yeah and
you know that there's some cross over
there even probably politically like a
quick current example I know is like the
daily wire they came out with that
Jeremy's chocolate thing yeah and they
sold 200 000 bars 36 hours so I mean
people can be I mean that's I mean we're
talking about a very like politically
right-wing example of something but yeah
you you see how loyal people are like
they'll respond uh with the dollar very
quickly if they believe in what you're
doing it made me want to buy it so yeah
uh one of the things that Rob said on
Glenn back
Glenn Beck said how far are you willing
to go with this and he said I'm willing
to I'm willing to risk my entire career
wow going into like the more Christian
realm of things uh while they're talking
about his his viewpoint on Politics as
viewpoint on church and it's very
unpopular with Hollywood yeah very
unpopular for sure yeah Scotty who is on
the show a lot um he talks about when
people when he was working in Hollywood
found out that he was a Christian and
man their whole they just changed on
they just flipped on him like oh you're
a Christian like oh homophobe and all
this stuff you know just immediately
labeling him judging him just because
he's a Christian in Hollywood
yeah I will say uh there are there's a
there's a good chunk of people that work
that we would consider Hollywood the
creators of mainstream content movies in
particular
who are very very enthusiastic about
being friends with the body of Christ a
Kevin Sorbo for instance he's making
some really good movies and he's very
adamant about his faith and why he got
out of Hollywood there are there's a lot
of non-christians that are like uh this
country needs to be turned around yeah
we need to be doing stuff for church
people to help church people turn our
country around that's their their
attitude so how can I participate or
contribute in that movement yeah I think
the pendulum is swinging so far left
that people are like whoa this is not
good we thought we wanted this but now
we're seeing where it's leading we need
a change yeah I mean when you start
getting into
normalizing things that should have
never been normalized yes so do you have
any tips for Christian content creators
um
yeah a
um be super bald Don't Be Afraid yeah so
if you're a Christian content creator
you're expected to make Christian
content
um where the atheist is set up to fail
and
yeah
um it's US versus them
and that's that's the attitude amongst a
lot of a lot of people in that space
Gaza did a great example where the
teacher you know and yeah I mean God's
Not Dead no you guys have made the movie
I love you guys and I'm friends with
those guys
um but I will say yeah I own the movie I
like the movie but I've seen a divided
it divided more than it brought together
I've seen a review is like why Christian
movies are terrible and it's popular
video on YouTube yeah and he's talking
about it's the same thing it's always
like the atheist is you know believes
that we were monkeys and all that stuff
and they just yeah they they try to be
little atheists and stuff yeah yeah and
I I don't go for that I I love I love
the atheists uh I I really want to I
really want to love on them and be their
friends and it's probably a jerk
reaction because of how Hollywood loves
to dog on Russian and it is like well
this is Jesus right so many Christian
content creators are following are
stooping that low it's like oh
it's not good you know but to answer the
question a lot of them are afraid to
think outside the box and do something
that's risky um I'm a huge risk taker
myself
I do what God tells me to do and I don't
care for who thinks what like the the
thought of man is irrelevant to God's
will in my life
um
secondly I would suggest that um don't
be afraid to partner with people that
know what they're doing even though
they're non-believer because
again there's a misconception that
people that don't believe in Jesus hate
the hate those of us that do in the in
the media world and that's simply not
really true because people that don't
believe in Jesus believe in the dollar
okay so they'll still work you move
um the problem is is people are like
well we need to do our thing well
Hollywood's doing their thing and the
answer is no we need to leverage
Hollywood to build the body of Christ
how do we
okay interesting these are good uh so so
getting like dusting off the table and
getting a clean slate and getting rid of
that hard that hard line that that's
Binger on um
and uh third I would say for Christian
content creators um
if you really think you have a calling
to make the content
look at what the content is
and ask yourself
are you being a hardcore
expert that's going to defy everything
that you can defy in the laws of
creation and the laws of
Entrepreneurship
and and be the beacon of professionalism
in that space
and if you're not going to do that then
I would say to hold off for a little bit
and until you're ready in your heart to
go down that Hard Road of
being like an expert in a craft
takes a lot of beatings and you have to
be willing to take those beatings I
always I always use the term with my
kids to throw the throws and take the
blows
and
you know go you're going into Warfare
anytime you cross the threshold of
Entrepreneurship to create something
you're going into some kind of warfare
and if your product can't withstand that
fight and it's going to fail and it's
just gonna dwindle to nothing because it
couldn't out it couldn't Outlast that
test then don't do it yeah because the
reason we see so many failed attempts at
Christian content creation is because
um the what the product that they were
creating could not withstand the
pressure that is going to be put under
which is scrutiny and you're creating a
product in this Christian creators we
need to create products that are the
beacon of perfection period and you need
to go through those processes and when
people say hey I read this script and
I'm sorry but stopping for prayer like
in this moment or having on one side of
the road us and on the other side of the
road them and it's just us versus them
thing like really think about those
moments in your script and when people
read it and they say hey this thing
sucks then accept the fact that people
think that it sucks and make something
that people think that's great yeah
um
when you talk to retail outlets if you
talk to
any distributor in the space if you say
hey I'm a Christian content creator
they're like yeah right you know
go over there and have talk to them you
know don't talk to me about it and it's
embarrassing that we've put ourselves in
this position
um but there is there is a new
generation of of Christian Media
creators
on the horizon it's because they're
getting smart you know the consumer is
the ultimate task right if the consumer
likes it they drop dollars on the table
oh
but before it gets to the consumer
can your product is it good for
Partnerships and are you getting like
really good Partnerships
so movie night is really built on the
idea that
uh people say David you can't start a
new streaming platform or you can't
start a new Distribution Company because
you know it's just another drum and
beating the same beat everybody else's
and it's really expensive and the answer
to that is um no it's not because if you
create something great you're going to
get a lot of great organizations that
come up and you're going to ride a lot
of coattails because the product is
great
um so if you're creating content that
also that you can't get Partnerships for
then I would say go back and go back to
the drawing board erase the white card
and grab another marker and kind of
start over right yeah okay it's not
always an agenda against the person or
an attack it might be something that you
need to analyze and figure out how to
make the product better yeah I love what
you said about Partnerships because some
this might be a misconception that in
order to be a Christian content creator
you have to be a creative but there's a
need for analytical Minds as well using
your skill to partner with the creative
to make something work yeah so being a
Christian content creator involves so
many facets that just as you were saying
thinking outside the box how can people
get involved you know just think think
about that what talent do I have that
could help someone who they may have a
weakness in and we all can get together
and and you know make an impact for the
world from a Christian's perspective
yeah right here we got lighting and CG
and right uh finance and I mean there's
all kinds of things to think about yeah
well uh critical Minds save investors
lasting lots of money you know and you
need to receive that criticism
uh as an entrepreneur
um anybody in here who's launched a
company you've done a logo like you guys
are working on a logo right now
um I do logo transest we get thousands
and thousands of logos
and when I first started doing that I
would I would be so soft and gentle hey
that's like that's okay I'm gonna think
about it right yeah yeah and then you
get like 200 designs okay if you go in
and say hey that sucks but I'm looking
for this can you please submit another
design you get thousands because you're
a you're you're like smashing the stuff
that you don't like and you're getting
new stuff that comes out and I that's
something I had to learn about myself is
you have to be more honest when you're
doing creative work because that
creative work has to be morphed and
involved and molded before it's
something that you can present to the to
a wide audience like our first movie
night logo when I first saw I'm like oh
that's really nice
and I look at it now and think oh my
gosh oh my God is that it says horrible
yeah it was horrible yeah you know yeah
brutal honesty it's hard sometimes yeah
but we
um
I get people with scripts all the time
and they send it to me and I can see the
look on their face when they hand it to
me if it's good or not because if they
can tell it's no good and they're handed
to me they might even tell the snippet
right so I know I'm gonna like I look at
him I'm like hey if I read this is it
going to waste my time like do you know
this is not good and they'll be like
well
we're gonna redo it okay then redo it
yeah
scraps I've read I read it a snail's
pace yeah and uh my right eye travels
faster than my left eye when I read so I
read like one line and then I forget
what line said so I gotta go back and
like pay attention next time right it's
any scripts take me forever so everybody
out there wants to send me a send a
scripts to movie night if I don't read
them I'm very sorry it takes a long time
what I like about both sides of this
thing is it's not just something that
you're doing or you're doing like this
offers
a platform for creatives like I know
somebody right now who's the son of a a
very well-known pastor and he's going to
college to take animation where is he
gonna go right Pixar you're gonna go to
Disney right a pastor's son like we need
we need something out there where you
can use these gifts for God's glory or
at least for some moral uh lesson that's
going to bring people to the body of
Christ yeah and I think that's a great
thing to create that platform for people
to for creatives that have somewhere to
go yeah well there's a huge myth out
there that
uh there's no money for Christian
content that is a myth and the truth is
there are billions and billions of
dollars out there of people that love
the Lord just as much as we hear on this
couch Dave and they're ready to finance
really cool stuff yeah
um
so guys like the pastor son
um he you know where is he gonna go
um
there's the movement on the horizon and
there's there's a lot of money available
for people making great stuff and we
have to
we have to as a community of Christian
content creators make
perfect product great product it has to
represent
has to be better than everything else
out there and to expand on what he's
saying I think that has been
um where where the Christian networking
has been lacking I mean if if Hollywood
can do this and they all Network
together we have God on our side and God
Is Bigger Than Hollywood yeah so if
Hollywood can produce all this quality
animation these amazing books we can do
the same thing people it seems like a
lot of the Christian Community have this
mentality that oh we don't have the
funding to do this or you know we're not
as big as Disney
no we are bigger than Disney we are
bigger than Hollywood because God Is
Bigger Than Disney and God Is Bigger
Than Hollywood but we just need to
network together and have faith in God
that we can do this we can do this
together Bubba says you have not because
you ask not and there's a lot of wealthy
people out there that that's their
Ministry I they feel like you know I
don't have talents but I have money and
I want to give it to people but they
don't know who to give it to if you
don't ask and asking for money is a hard
thing to do we want those people to come
to us and feel confident that we can
help them with The Inspirations that God
has given them yeah make their dreams
come true you know if it can happen for
Disney it can happen for Christians
through God yeah you know Disney people
work hard and
God says the diligent will receive their
reward that's right and I think if we're
gonna you know we should be
putting our best efforts for the kingdom
of God that's right that's interesting
okay so if someone has an idea it takes
money to make the idea work yeah right
but then there seems to be a cycle where
you have to make something of quality so
people to pay for it but to get the
quality you need the money so how do how
does the balance yeah yeah so um
as an entrepreneur I've been involved in
Lots I've been involved in startup life
has been my life for him since I get out
of high school uh and I have raised
quite a bit of money
and
when I decided to do movie night
um
it was years ago when I when I wanted to
do that but when God prompted me and
said it's time now when Rob called and
said the movie's ready and I'm living
out of the truck with no money uh
I'm like okay Lord
um
my model is either gonna sell to
investors without me having to pitch
them or not but if I've got a hard close
investors to raise money it's because my
model sucks
and the very first meeting I went to
without even opening my mouth I got to
give me 100 grand
um and
you know our firsts our first several
hundred thousand dollars came without me
having to ask for money and then people
hear about it they saw the film no they
just heard about the model and said I
think this is a great investment uh can
you can I invest in your company
so sometimes it doesn't even take the
product it takes good organizational
back end yeah so yeah yeah so some some
investors bet on the jockey some
investors bet on the horse Okay
um get an analogy my my career as an
entrepreneur has been people betting on
the jockey
because like David you're hyper
aggressive you're hyper enthusiastic and
you're not going to fail I'm gonna bet
on you
um is your tattoo removal company gonna
be the seven billion dollar Giants you
know I don't care but I'm gonna I think
you're gonna pull it off so I'll bet on
you
um
with movie night they look at that and
say this horse
is going to win hmm
they put money on the horse yeah so
uh
you know the Bible talks about a prophet
not being welcome in his hometown
if anybody's connected to wealth it's
this guy right here I know
a lot of people have a lot of money
um
and
I thought to myself this is going to be
easy raising money I'm gonna call my
friends and just raise a couple million
bucks right I start calling my friends
I'm like Dave look at you man he just
went through a divorce and you're living
out of a truck and you want me to give
you money
you need to get on your feet first
before the best yeah I've heard that
right so the first couple calls I I made
I'm like okay Lord
um
you know I guess
I guess I'm gonna get money from people
I don't know or something every single
event I've been to every time every stop
I've made in my travels someone says I'm
going to put money in your company
in the same time
uh we went down the road and said let's
raise a million
um
no I said let's raise three million
and
I got five million dollars in interest
so I thought wait a minute I'm raising
it way too low of value okay if it's
that easy
um so our little startup we've we've
raised a million bucks on the 50 million
dollar valuation for a startup that has
no revenue and no product
okay it's because of
uh a god inspired plan with God inspired
executors for the plan
so but it's taking
uh since the movie event I went to in
2006. it took a long time to craft the
plan and do the research
and I started four organizations to do
this that didn't get off the ground
before getting to this one
and I've traveled everywhere in North
America I've met with every pastor and
Movie Maker you can imagine in the last
15 years
and it's been hundreds and hundreds of
doors shut and hardened carbs hardened
and to get to the point where I had to
be completely broken on the complete and
tunnel bottom living out of a car wow
that most reminds me of the story of job
you know yeah look what he went through
but ultimately he was he got the
blessings of God and yeah that's what he
had to go through Not only was I almost
said thousands of blisters all over my
body yeah so you had the blisters too
uh my entire circle closed their doors
to me and
um yeah it was a shocker to think there
was like a humbling process that came
with that because you were like yeah and
make this easy and then it was like
yeah what from the intention of the guy
that brings everybody to church to see
movies to
um the guy that's just really
just a guy yeah you know that's right
wow but yeah the Lord humbled me pretty
yeah and in all lives in all our
partnering let's not forget to partner
with God Amen that's the most important
partner of mine and make a way and give
guidance and really pick that one idea
that's really gonna work yeah and we can
come up with a bunch right but which one
he can see the future he knows which one
has been one of the best that's right
yeah he knows what's best for us as him
I would um frequently forget about uh
the fruit of the Holy Spirit the the
patience part right spirit is number one
there's many biblical examples of people
forgetting that yeah this has been
awesome I'm so thankful to have you guys
on and to talk about this topic because
it comes up a lot you know and I I want
people out there to use their gifts for
God and to give it all they have and I
just think this is a really good
discussion to talk about things to think
about so if you guys were blessed by
this don't forget to click like on there
it's a simple and free way to get this
video onto the algorithm if you're new
click subscribe and we got a share on
there so you can share this with all
your family and friends and uh we love
you and we'll see you guys next time
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you